a lone whale adrift at sea a million
meters cubed of no response he calls at
the wrong frequency listen to the call
of what is considered to be the
loneliest whale in the world
this call is at a frequency of 52 Hertz
this frequency is very unusual for a
whale with most whales calling at around
team 240 Hertz this call comes from what
appears to be the only whale in the
ocean at this pitch now listen to the
call of the blue whale to compare
both of these sounds have been speed up
10 times so that we can hear them easily
and humans are not the only ones with a
hearing limit whales use sound to
communicate to swim with others and to
find a mate it is thought that the
sounds of the 52 Hertz whale cannot be
heard by any others and thus it is
destined to forever swim alone singing
out with no reply ideas are that the
whale could be malformed a hybrid
between a blue whale and another species
or deaf as the sounds we make can be
influenced by the sounds we hear this is
definitely a poignant story that makes
us think about the projection of human
emotions we all feel isolated at times
familiar with the idea that despite our
attempts we are not heard or seen that
we are alone in a crowded sea does this
whale feel loneliness I don't know how
can we know detected first in 1989 it
has been swimming alone for over 25
years if what has ever known
is solitude would it still miss a crowd
I would imagine a sense of peace comes
with accepting that life is just the
cool water breaking over your fin but
humans would find that hard to accept do
you think you could still appreciate
beauty in life if you had no one like
you to share it with